dernier raccord maquillage dernier
ajustement technique moteur demandé
séquence 20 25 plants sains première
action c'est parti pour sept jours de
tournage dans la campagne berrichonne
maxime et yoann n'en sont pas à leur
coup d'essai il réalise aujourd'hui leur
deuxième film un moyen métrage de 40
minutes maxime originaire de châteauroux
est un touche-à-tout tantôt comédiens
tantôt danseurs aujourd'hui c'est la
casquette de réalisateur qu'il porte
toujours très attaché à ses terres nous
avons choisi le berry pour le pour son
patrimoine
parce qu'il recèle le patrimoine qui
n'est pas assez exploité et d'ailleurs
c'est mon co réalisateur parisien qui en
venant lors d'un voyage et à quelques
années il a vu le patrimoine je vais
fait d'éviter des châteaux des manoirs
comme celui là et il m'a dit mais il
faut absolument qu'on s'arrête dans
cette province dans ce berry pourrait
faire un sujet est donc un sujet dans
les années 30
sur les trente six comédiens de cette
fiction près de la moitié sont
originaires de la région dont muriel
castelroussine et fanny venu d'argenton
sur creuse
elles ont toutes deux déjà participé au
premier film j'ai jamais fait ou avant
donc j'ai commencé par de la figuration
il ya deux ans dans le premier volet et
puis là un petit rôle avec quelques
phrases quelques phrases à dire et et
voilà mais non c'est une super
expérience sont nés dans les années 1940
donc oui on tourner certaines scènes ici
pour faire découvrir aussi le berry
notre région est donc un plaisir aussi
de mettre en avant notre région à
l'histoire mènera l'équipe sur plus de
dix lieux de tournage pour mettre en
boîte les 50 séquence après le manoir de
foule que tiers ils seront dans le vieux
château ou en garde écueil et la semaine
prochaine sortie du film prévue pour
l'été 2010 9